you got to work out like what direction
are you are you walking towards and
that's probably the most challenging
thing of like working out what it is
that that you want to be and Achieve um
and I knew that I love rugby so as a
passion one you got to actually work out
what you're good at and and what you
love doing and if you have those things
then you can start moving in the right
direction of what you want to achieve
you know what is your uh your purpose
and and this part of of of your life
because it will change uh very stages of
of your life and you know I experience
that having finished finished plane and
it's a a thing that you need to to spend
time and and think about and and once
you have that the power of of personal
purpose is you know is really
important